you remember when Robert Muller said he
would prefer not to testify well that
was then and this is now the former
special counsel has agreed to testify in
public next month before two
congressional committees after House
Democrats issued a subpoena brother Dan
Trump is sounding off on what is sure to
be a blockbuster hearing at what point
does it end it's a disgrace no
obstruction no collision now the
Democrats want to do over so they had to
do over in the house that didn't work
they had to do over in the Senate that
didn't work there are no do-overs we
spent a long time working with Muller I
gave them all the witnesses he wanted I
gave them lawyers I gave them people I
guess he interviewed 500 people 2,500
subpoenas they had everything they could
possibly have nobody's ever had more
nobody's ever been more transparent and
now it continues further this is just a
hoax top Republicans calling it
political theater saying this move could
backfire on Democrats here are
congressman mark meadows and Democratic
congressman Adam Schiff what I find just
so disheartening is is that Bob Muller
said it all
445 pages that's all I'm going to say
and what has he been doing he's been
courted by the other side just so that
they can arrest the president and keep
on this narrative he did not want to
testify he made that very clear
nonetheless they will respect the
subpoena he will appear if you're gonna
accept the role a special counsel and
one of the most significant
investigations in modern history you're
gonna have to expect that you're gonna
be asked to come and testify before
Congress and of course the media has
taken notice hyping this as a must-see
event this is what the American people
have been waiting for since the Muller
report was released to us in the form
that we got he's gonna speak in front of
two committees on the same day that's a
lot the nine minute appearance was the
the trailer for the movie we're about to
see I think it's big I think it's a real
breakthrough for the the Congress for
the house I think it could really define
the remainder of the Trump presidency
Gregg just when you thought it was a
your chance to enjoy the summer
yes fact they think it's a summer
blockbuster but it's just a lousy sequel
and it's it's like jaws in 3d it's
actually going to destroy the Moller
franchise because even the people that
the more sensible Democrats are going
you got to let this go because what's
happening is you're focusing all your
energy on this this drug and you're not
focusing on issues which you should be
doing if essentially they're leaving the
drug addict with enough supply to kill
themselves
they're very feeding them collusion
smack and and and they can't even admit
that they're addicted to it so they're
constantly going back to it and they're
gonna end up destroying their chances
for any reelection because they look
like they're obsessed over something and
it's sad to hear them talk like that
because they talk like addicts oh this
is gonna be the one this is gonna be it
oh this is gonna be great all right how
much is it how much do we have is this
gonna last it's sad to hear them sound
like that because you realize they're
trapped in a delusion it's kind of funny
when you think about it it is a little
bit funny Jesse the risk I think that
Democrats have here is that when Miller
did the little statement that he had he
basically said he didn't have a problem
with how William bar the Attorney
General had handled the report is again
I'm good said I I don't really want to
testify I'm not gonna say anything
outside of this report so well the
Democrats risk you this big buildup and
then yet again nothing well I think
there's gonna be a lot of action on the
Republican side because Muller's never
been cross-examined before we know what
he's going to say when the Democrats ask
the questions he's going to stick to his
400 page script but the Republicans
can't wait to sink their teeth into this
guy on live television I spoke to a
Republican today who's going to grill
him and he said listen foreign
interference you were supposed to
investigate why Jolie look at one side
how come you never looked at the
Ukrainians giving the mana for documents
to the DNC or Chris Steele
drumming up all that stuff from Russia
how about when did you know there was no
collusion was it before the midterms how
about why did you stack your entire team
with partisan Democrats the top
lieutenant was crying on stage with
Hillary as she lost the election there's
a lot of questions you can ask and I
don't think he's gonna
very well and his Greg said the real
run-of-the-mill Democrats out in the
country they care about global warming
more than they care about this and that
says a lot there and this is gonna fire
up the Republican bill you said about
Medicare all Medicare for about that
tonight Juan what do you think about all
this well I'm just so surprised I mean I
was watching the president talk on Maria
Bartiromo show this morning and they
thought occurred to me why is the
attacking Robert Moore I think that he
says no obstruction no collusion on the
basis of the Mulla report so if the
Muller report is so good for him why is
the attacking Muller and why are
Republicans reacting as if oh the
Democrats are the ones that are just so
hungry to put Muller on display well
that's the case if mower is like someone
who has exonerated the president you
would think the president would
therefore say I welcome having him
testify but that's not the reaction I'm
getting so I'm thinking hey something's
going on here one there's the Democrats
still don't have an unredacted report
they don't they say they don't Katie
report not only yes I think that when
Muller gave his 9 minute report he did
challenge Bob Barr he did change the
perception because bars been out there
saying nothing here don't look anybody
and I backed mother said you know what
really clear obstruction but you know
what let Congress proceed I don't think
it's my role given the inspector given
the Justice Department policy on in
dying a sitting president so I think
that there's lots here but it's just
interesting that the president is
attacking Muller well Phil Barr used to
victim yeah bill Barr specifically
didn't want to release the report in
chunks because he wanted to be more
transparent with the American people and
therefore he released the entire report
without grand jury information revealed
which is something that every single
American should want because it's a
privacy protection issue for every
single person but going to the questions
that are going to be asked about the
other Moeller
to Moeller I think Democrats are going
to be asking him very specifically why
didn't you yourself come up with a
requirement or
something on obstruction like why didn't
you come up a decision a decision on
obstruction why did you give that to
bill bar to decide instead of deciding
that with your team of attorneys and
coming up with that because that has
been a big point of political contention
he didn't want to testify because he
didn't want to become a political
football and when Rachel Maddow says the
Americans have been waiting for this
moment no this is like the bottom of the
barrel when it comes to what people are
interested in and the president is
frustrated with it because he wants to
actually move on and have Democrats work
on other things besides what he calls
the witch-hunt do you accept a lot of
time a can I use an analogy that
involves golf oh wow let's hear it yes I
think the media has a golf bag of clubs
that they use on Trump right but they
aren't getting hit they aren't getting
them to the green they're always in the
rough which is not a good place so one
day it's collusion the next day it's
mental instability that's a club then
it's is he gonna serve a third term that
was a club torturing kids that was a
club so now they're reaching in and the
they they're going back to the collusion
Club but they're shooting like a 150 and
it's a nine-hole course running out
they're running out of clubs running so
they're going back to the old club which
is collusion I also imagine that ball
sorry Bob Muller is going to be like I
didn't want to be here guys asked for it
and he's a good witness you saw in his
press conference he did not look happy
to be there he didn't look sharp he
didn't look energized and he's gonna
face really tough question he looked
energized then he would have been
criticized for being like I don't say oh
my god she's angry when is the last time
he's had to face tough questioning under
oath in a live setting when all the
cameras are there I think Weitzman
carried that investigation and he
doesn't want to be there when they ask
him he'll maybe it's going to the bus
you made columbic out to be this
sinister Russian agent he was your
source he's been feeding the Americans
your wish because maybe some of the
Democrats will get some of Muller staff
to come testify maybe they'll
ha hey Donna to do it behind closed
doors that's my point but also why did
you have Donald Trump testified that he
take the fifth what's about young to you
well we don't know why no we didn't take
why didn't you testify why didn't you
detective this all Hilary's team we're
gonna do what the American people want
and we're gonna move on